the awesome second season of the
umbrella academy just exploded onto our
screens with the gang arriving in the
60s to meddle with the timeline stop in
the apocalypse and leave us with yet
another epic cliffhanger for season
three
yipikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video we're breaking down everything you
need to know about that big twist ending
including clues you might have missed
about the new characters upgraded
umbrella academy powers and what it all
means for season three
it goes without saying spoilers ahead so
take care
season 2 ends on an almighty cliffhanger
when the umbrella academy returned from
the 60s to 2019
only to discover things are not as they
expected not only is there a portrait of
ben on the wall at the academy where the
portrait of five
used to be but their father reginald
hargreaves is still alive and he drops
this bombshell
this isn't your home this is the sparrow
academy a mystery group of five assemble
above and ben
2.0 strides into view dad who the hell
are these [ __ ] this is a huge wtf
moment for the umbrella academy who
suddenly discover they have no home and
no obvious future
first off some interesting details to
point out are that ben who's of course
alive in this new timeline
seems to be the sparrow academy leader
the equivalent of the umbrella cruise
luther aka number one
notice the scar on his face which he
presumably acquired on a mission
and also the coat of arms on his jacket
which has a sparrow in the top left
quarter rather
than an umbrella something else you
might have missed is a mystery cube that
floats into view next to the other
sparrows on the balcony
the cube has some glowing green light
inside and although it could be some
kind of device or invention that the
sparrows use it might also be the
seventh member of the team
perhaps even a character who died like
original ben
and whose consciousness is contained
within the cube perhaps a bit like robot
man from doom patrol
or if the cube itself is sentient it
makes me think of the talking ai
mainframe which appears in one of the
guardians of the galaxy 2 post-credits
scenes
i miss you guys so much if the cube is
just a piece of tech though
i wonder if the fact that there are only
six sparrows on screen could imply that
one of them is dead or that there's a
supposedly non-powered sibling like
vonya aka 7 who's not yet part of their
super team
in the comics the sparrow academy is a
group of superheroes who turn up at the
very end of the third volume of books to
take down a group of villains rampaging
through the city
they seem more capable than the umbrella
academy who were basically losing the
battle until the sparrows arrive
their leader calls themselves number one
but they have different powers to the
umbrella team
and the comic book sparrows also have a
cube that floats alongside them
gerard way the comics writer and
producer on the netflix show
has said that the next volume in the
comics will begin to answer questions
about the other super babies which
strongly implies that the sparrows are
indeed other babies born on that fateful
day the tv show will doubtless have its
own plans that will differ in some ways
from the comics but what's especially
interesting
is that there were sparrow motifs hidden
all through the second season
foreshadowing the introduction of this
new team and you can see those secret
sparrows in my upcoming things you
missed video
but how did the sparrow academy come
about was reginald hargreaves so
unimpressed with the umbrella team he
met in 1963 that he decided to form an
alternative supergroup the sparrow
academy thank you for coming
i've seen about enough or did the
umbrella crew alter the timeline so
badly in season two that they
accidentally wrote themselves out of the
future
let's review the season's big events for
evidence and how this points
the existence of an umbrella academy
multiverse
one of the crucial moments in season two
that connects directly to the events of
the first season
is when old man five time travels
through a portal from 1963 to 2019.
in season 2 we see old man five fall
backwards through the portal into 2019
rather than falling through face
forwards as he did in season one
and the five that jumps forward in time
to 2019 in season two
also has a whole lot of different
information to what he had in the first
season
for example luther already told him that
the eyeball he found in the apocalypse
is just a red herring that's a waste of
time
and why were you holding it when i found
you dead in the apocalypse no idea but
the guy i belonged who didn't end the
world banya did
the eyeball luth is referring to
belonged to leonard and so now when five
arrives in 2019 it won't make sense for
him to chase down
leads on where the eye came from as he'd
surely immediately tell the others about
vonya
which means he will end up creating an
alternate timeline
we've already seen the show touch and
alternate timelines in the first season
for example episode six the day that
wasn't
but at the end of that episode when five
time jumped to an earlier point in that
day
the show followed on and began an
alternate timeline in which allison and
luther never had that kiss
we have never even kissed and there are
so many other examples in season two of
major effects that the super siblings
must have had on the timeline that it's
easy to see why the gang arrived back in
a rather different 2019
as vanya pointed out in the 60s has
anyone here done anything to screw up
the timeline klaus for example starts a
cult that attracts at least a few
hundred followers and tries to convince
dave not to sign up to fight in vietnam
in fact there's a clue in the sixth
episode that the timeline was already
changing
when klaus discovers that dame is
enlisted in the army days before it
originally happened
and by the final episode the whole
umbrella crew end up on the national
news as persons of interest in the jfk
assassination
something which could have myriad
repercussions on the timeline
in addition to that five killed the
commission's board of directors which
means the commission's decisions on how
they want the timeline to proceed could
be very different now which could lead
to the formation of the sparrow academy
and given reginald hargreaves is still
alive in the new timeline it's fair to
assume that pogo and grace who were
killed during vanya's destructive
rampage in season 1
will also be back in season 3. a crucial
new
character who will surely be returning
is lila who in the finale turned out to
be one of the 43 super powered babies
born on the same day in 1989.
lila's power set is fascinating as she
can reproduce the abilities of any of
the umbrella academy members in certain
circumstances
for example when vanya flattens the
handler's army of assassins with an
energy blast
lila was able to replicate vonyu's
defensive powers by creating a shield
that protected both her
and the handler lyla can also mirror
vonya's other powers such as when she
sent a powerful blast against the
umbrella crew
on top of that lila was also able to
redirect alison's rumor back at her
almost killing her i heard a rumor you
stopped breathing
and she also took on luther's brute
strength when he tried to hit her
although lila's huge power reveal was a
surprise in the finale there was
actually a hint to her ability to mirror
other people's powers during her
mid-season fight with five when she was
able to blink just like he does
how are you doing this oh anything that
you can do i can do better
lyla's ability to mimic other hero's
superpowers reminds me of the marvel
villain task master who appears in the
new black widow movie
so unoriginal it seems that lila's
abilities may be something that's
triggered temporarily such as when
another superpowered individual uses
their powers
because she doesn't seem to use her
superpowers any other time
lila has a troubled backstory with five
having killed her parents after the
handler placed a kill order on them so
she could adopt the gifted girl for
herself so diego suggested she joined
the umbrella academy who he said were
her real family
however she ended up escaping with a
commission briefcase to an
unknown time and location is it possible
that lila is one of the members of the
sparrow academy
either way she's far too interesting a
character not to return at some point
as for lyla's adoptive mother the
handler by the end of season two her
double dealings with the swedes and her
scheming against the umbrella academy
finally catch up with her
as the sole surviving swede guns her
down presumably she's dead for good this
time however that also appeared to be
the case in season one when hazel shot
her in the head but she survived thanks
to the metal plate in her head
i wouldn't quite put it past her
returning in the future as she was such
a fantastic character with their schemes
and
outfits getting more and more outrageous
as their powers grew within the
commission
though i suspect if she does reappear
it'll be in flashbacks or yes another
alternate timeline
although the umbrella academy's very
existence comes into question when they
get back to 2019
by the end of season 2 the team are
actually much stronger and more mature
with a better understanding of who they
really are and better control over their
powers which will be important for
season three
bonya and ben perhaps go through the
biggest arc with their fates converging
in an emotional ninth episode
when vonya arrives in 1963 she loses her
memory after being hit by sissy's car so
she starts with a blank slate and seems
more comfortable in her own skin than in
the first season
not surprising given that now she's not
being mistreated
constantly made to feel she's worthless
or incessantly compared to her super
siblings
and as she rediscovers who she really is
this time unlike in season 1 she has
much more control over her powers
she's able to voluntarily levitate a
whole body of water in order to rescue
harlan
and she breezily demonstrates how she
can manipulate a sound wave in front of
hargreaves and her siblings
she can even turn into the white violin
at will as a way of warning
five and then quickly turn it off as
well she has control over her energy
blasts now and curiously she almost
seemed to make the fbi agent's face
implode when he was interrogating her
however when she's drugged by the feds
and electro shocked bonya's memories of
what she did in the first season
including attacking her sister allison
and destroying the world
come flooding back you can't deny your
true self any longer even if you are
afraid
and the emotional overload sends vonya's
powers out of control again
that's when ben becomes the hero of the
moment because as a ghost he's the only
one who can withstand the physical force
that's blasting out from vonya
ben uses his newfound ability of
possessing another body to enter vanya's
psyche and communicate with her
he helps his sister come to terms with
her powers and explains that she
isn't a monster and that her siblings
love her and are out there fighting to
help her the brotherly love that ben
shares with vanya in this moment
is very touching and restores her sense
of self-worth
bringing her back from the brink of
destruction this experience also gives
ben the resolution he's been looking for
for 17 years to leave his current plane
of existence
there's a really nice visual of ben
walking towards the light
as he goes to help vania which relates
the conversation he had with his brother
claus at his own funeral
there's a light and they told me to walk
into it that thing don't worry about it
you can go whatever you want
as for the others klaus develops his
ability to manifest ghosts other than
ben in the real world
when lila's blast sends him flying for a
potentially lethal fool he summons a
couple of ghosts to catch him safely and
in the 1963 apocalypse we got a glimpse
of the potential of his powers when he
summoned an
army of the dead to attack the invading
soldiers
five finally masters time travel by
limiting his attempts to travel back in
time to just a few seconds or minutes
rather than whole years or decades at
once
and with this skill he's able to reverse
everyone's brutal deaths by the handler
alison was unable to speak for a year
until her throat wound healed and
because she couldn't use her power
she felt more like everything she
accomplished was earned
given the situation she lands in though
her inability then reluctance to use her
powers can feel more frustrating than
usual
but as emmy raver lantman told den of
geek alison sees her power as more of a
curse than a blessing
as it's always backfired in the long
game still by the end of season 2
alison seems to feel she's found the
right balance of when to call on her
ability
diego spends much of season 2 really
playing up to his hero complex
and although it's not entirely clear
whether he's resolved that his power to
manipulate objects in mid-air gets an
upgrade in the final showdown when he's
able to redirect an enormous hail of
bullets
and then there was that pretty awesome
moment during the 1963 apocalypse when
if you look really closely
diego is bending this stream of bullets
away from him as he spirals through the
air
in terms of their personal lives though
in many ways the gang loses more than
they gain
vania finds a soulmate in [ __ ] but the
dangers of life as a superpowered
individual means sissy's scared for
harlan's safety if she goes with vania
however a door is left open for a
reunion down the road
you never find the safe way back to me
you take it if funyu wanted to leave
the team or settle down she could grab a
commission briefcase and travel back in
time to be with her
similar to how hazel enjoyed his golden
years with agnes in another timeline
each of the others also loses someone
important to them diego loses lila to
the timeline
although there's a good chance they will
meet again and allison had to give up
her marriage with rey
klaus wasn't able to convince dave not
to go to vietnam
and when ben leaves the earthly plane
he's no longer able to see the girl he
likes from klaus's cult
as for luther when jack ruby disowns him
he loses a father figure he never had
i treated you like a son okay
time to discuss harlan sissy's son who
has gifted vania's telekinetic powers
when she resuscitated him after he
appeared to drown
those little lights that transferred
into him seemed to confirm the theory
that the glowing lights we saw
hargreaves released in the season one
finale are connected to the special
powers inherited by bonya
and likely all 43 super babies born in
1989.
harlan's manifestation of powers
triggers a major alarm at the commission
with the handler recognizing the
importance of the event which is why she
went immediately to take harlem for
herself
like she did with lyla interestingly
though the transference of power from
vania to harlan connects them both even
across distances
harlan goes into a trance when vonya is
being tortured by the fbi
and emerges from it at the same time she
comes out of her shock
harlan can also repel a bullet fired at
him just like vonya did when the swedes
tried to shoot her
and similar to vonya in season 1 when
harlan's emotions get out of control
after the deflected bullet accidentally
kills his father he begins to go
supernova
bonya eventually is able to calm him
down when she removes those golden
lights from his body
however as we see later when he's
levitating one of his bird toys
he still retains at least some of the
powers she gave him which makes me
wonder whether harlem might grow up to
be the father of any of the members of
the sparrow academy
or even help form the group with
hargreaves
season two goes deeper into reginald
hargreaves backstory revealing that he
was working for a time with a shadowy
organization called the majestic 12.
he had a deal to trade them his rocket
technology in return for leaving alone
his interests on the dark side of the
moon
hargreaves objected to their
assassination of president kennedy and
attempted to leave the group
and when they tried to blackmail him we
got the awesome reveal that he's really
an alien hiding underneath human skin
we only get a glimpse of the back of his
head but the moment is a great nod to
the same reveal in the comics that
hargreaves wears a mask to blend in as a
human
which also explains why he never seems
to age something
i really enjoyed in season two was
getting to learn a lot more about the
commission and in particular the
infinite switchboard where operators
continually monitor the timeline for
anomalies and the commission's
all-seeing eye reminds me of how
whenever we're online our internet
service
providers are keeping records of our
browsing history and what that means for
our privacy which is why i want to thank
the sponsor of this video nordvpn who
offer one of the world's best virtual
private networks a vpn is essential to
prevent your internet service provider
tracking your online activities and
sharing your data with governments or
even selling it to advertisers
here at flix and the city we've tested
several vpns and we know that
some really slow down your connection
however nord strives to maintain
super fast download and upload speeds on
its 5000 plus servers through the use of
new generation vpn technologies like
wireguard
so when we tested nord we were still
able to get blisteringly fast download
speeds
and one of the best features of nordvpn
is that unlike many free vpns nord has a
no
log policy meaning it doesn't record or
retain details of your online activity
when you're connected to its service
nordvpn also helps you to connect to
many streaming services and can help you
bypass geo restrictions or censorship on
content not available to view in your
country
just pick a server in another location
and browse the internet as if you were
there
plus you can connect up to six devices
at the same time
including your laptop and phone so you
can keep your mobile devices safe
whenever you're traveling and using
public wi-fi for a limited time nordvpn
are offering all our viewers up to 70
off new subscriptions and a bonus month
absolutely free
just visit nordvpn.com or tap the link
in the video description to access the
offer
that's nordvpn.comflix for a huge 70
discount and an additional month for
free so which are your favorite moments
or characters in season two and do you
have any theories on the sparrow academy
or season three
more umbrella academy videos are on the
way including all the amazing details
you missed in season two
so be sure to subscribe and leave a
thumbs up if you enjoyed this
tap left to watch the next umbrella
academy video or tap right for something
else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yupikai movie lovers